[Música]
ah
es común escuchar en estos días
hay una isla de plástico en el medio del
océano pacifico overa imágenes como esta
o ver cuando vamos por la ruta plásticos
pegados en los alambrados y cosas por el
estilo
ante ese tipo de imágenes surge en
posiciones como
ay
que prohibió los plásticos posiciones
completamente fundamentalistas
y entonces posiciones entonces
desde hace más de 30 años que trabajo
con plásticos me preguntó y les he
preguntado a los fundamentalistas
ustedes se imaginan vivir sin plásticos
se imaginan que a partir de mañana no
usemos más plásticos les propongo un
pequeño ejercicio de abstracción vamos a
pensar en este momento mirarnos a
nosotros mismos a ver
que estamos usando de plásticos
empecemos por los anteojos por ejemplo
que yo no los tengo puesto pero los uso
los anteojos orgánicos porque tendemos a
usar cada vez más anteojos orgánicos
porque son mucho más livianos mucho más
cómodos y más baratos
además se consiguen mejores formas en
los vidrios
si seguimos por la boca adentro de la
boca tenemos prótesis las últimas
prótesis de que son de plástico
no hablemos de los maquillajes y de las
pinturas porque seguimos en la misma
tendencia y que de los hilos o de los
hilados con los que están hechos todos
nuestros vestidos todas nuestras ropas
más del 98% de los hilados son de algún
tipo de fibra polimérica de algún tipo
de fibra de plástico en la actualidad
porque porque son livianos porque tienen
bajo costo y porque se consiguen
performance de abrigo por ejemplo o de
refrigeración mucho mejores con que con
unas cuantas fibras naturales
seguimos pensemos en el calzado muy poco
calzado es de cuero pero aún ese calzado
de cuero que tiene tiene una suela que
es de goma en general y tiene un
interno que es de algún tipo de plástico
y si seguimos por los bolsos lo mismo
que hay adentro de los bolsos
el celular la birome etcétera etcétera
etcétera las cartucheras ese tipo de
cosas de que son de plásticos ok y en
que vinimos en que vinimos hasta acá si
vinimos en algún medio público vinimos
en automóvil ustedes saben que más del
60% en volumen de un automóvil actual es
de un material plástico eso equivale más
o menos al 40 por ciento en peso
podríamos tener entonces si hacemos una
abstracción de repente y decimos bueno
ok no más plásticos peak se van los
plásticos estamos desnudos no usamos más
celulares no tenemos más gomas en los
autos volvemos a los automóviles con
gomas
mejor hecho con gomas no fíjense hasta
qué punto con ruedas de madera hasta qué
punto tenemos internalizado el plástico
que en vez de decir rueda décimo goma
ahora bien podemos hacer eso tiene
sentido hacer eso tiene sentido ser
fundamentalista a ese nivel y acá cabe
una pregunta entonces por un lado lo
queremos prohibir pero por el otro lado
lo usamos continuamente entonces los
plásticos son buenos o son malos son
ángeles o son demonios que son los
plásticos si ustedes se ponen a pensar
en la cantidad de alimentos que llegan
en este momento a grandes urbes al
centro de una gran urbe como buenos
aires en excelentes condiciones
alimentarias y se fijan porque se van a
dar cuenta que para muchos para lograr
eso los plásticos fueron imprescindibles
eso se logra gracias a un envase
particular a un envase a medida
que otras cosas que otros beneficios
andrei de los plásticos piensen que han
permitido bajar la cantidad de bacterias
y virus en su propagación en los
hospitales a partir del uso de catéteres
cánulas etcétera etcétera y además
permiten la cicatrización mucho más
rápida de heridas a partir de parches
determinados y las suturas etcétera
etcétera etcétera
de nuevo entonces preguntémonos un
poquitito los plásticos son buenos o son
malos
veamos en los ejemplos que yo les he
dado hasta el momento si nosotros vemos
el tiempo de vida útil de esos de esos
plásticos vemos básicamente los podemos
dividir en dos grupos los plásticos de
larga duración o de larga vida y los
plásticos de corta vida entre los
primeros tenemos los de los automóviles
los de las prótesis los de los dientes
etcétera etcétera en los segundos
tenemos todo aquello que viene de
material descartable envases esos duran
muy corta vida su vida es muy corta y
entonces esos son los que normalmente
nosotros vemos en la imagen de la
tortuga vemos pegados en los alambrados
vemos tirados por todos lados las
botellas que juntan agua
sin embargo esos materiales que vemos
por todos lados
son materiales que si bien no son
biodegradables son inocuos al medio
ambiente desde su punto de vista de la
droga con la que fueron hechos
y pueden ser reciclados por reprocesado
en energía de una manera sostenible
y a nuestra respuesta y al perdón ya
nuestra pregunta son buenos o son malos
cuál es la respuesta pues ni lo uno ni
lo otro el problema no es el material el
problema es el que lo usa
el material si nosotros hacemos de un
material bueno un uso adecuado el
resultado bueno
así entonces el secreto parece ser el
gran secreto de todas las cosas en esta
vida hacernos cargo de lo que hacemos y
de lo que tiramos particularmente en los
plásticos de lo que usamos y de lo que
tiramos
cabe un ejemplo en este momento de una
cosa que me pasó hace muy poco tiempo
fui a comprar un regalo voy a comprar un
perfume para hacer un regalo
mire la fragancia etcétera etcétera
compraba 50 mililitros de perfume 50
mililitros de perfume caben en mi puño
si es un volumen pequeño típico de un
frasco de perfume
esos 50 mililitros venían en un frasco
divino divino hecho con tres materiales
no con uno era de vidrio el frasco era
de vidrio de metal y de plástico de una
manera estaba armado ese frasco que
estaba completamente mezclado el uno con
el otro
ese frasco venía dentro de una caja
hermosamente pintada y dibujada
en muchos colores
pero adentro eso tenía un cartoncito
corrugado que mantenía al frasco quieto
para que no se rompa durante el traslado
y todo eso sí he lado por una film
plástico que permitía garantizar que el
perfume era original
así estaba en la góndola entonces o en
el instante la persona que me lo vendió
lo tomo de ahí
y me pregunto si era para regalos pues
si era para regalos y ahí entonces
empezó le puso un envoltorio muy bonito
precioso lleno de colorines etcétera
etcétera y un moño que era más grande
que la caja del perfume y a su vez lo
metió adentro de una bolsa de cartón
hermosa mente impresa con también un
plastificado externo y como si esto
fuera poco tomó una especie de papel y
le puso unas alas que hacían hacia en la
bolsa ya fuera otro moño con una bolsita
para que yo pusiera la tarjetita que
dijera para pirula de silvia
bien yo había comprado 50 mililitros de
perfume que cabían en mi mano
sinceramente la bolsa era preciosa
realmente era bonito lo que yo estaba
viendo lo que estaba regalando ahora
se dan cuenta lo que había comprado y lo
que me dieron un poquito más adelante
vamos a volver a reflexionar sobre esto
qué hacemos con todo eso que nos dieron
qué hacemos cuando le llevamos a un niño
un regalo para su cumpleaños y el niño
acepta tiro todos los papeles y se
quedan en papel en la caja todos los
envoltorios de su juguete y se quedó con
su chiche
fíjense otra situación que es casi
habitual uno va al supermercado a
comprar verduras entonces tiene que
poner si compra de una tiene que poner
una un tomate morrón lo que fuere uno en
cada bolsita unas bolsitas pequeñitas
y va pesando de 1 llega y pesa de 1
cuando llega a la casa que hace con esas
bolsitas pues no sirven para otra cosa
que para la verdura para cada una de las
verduras y las desecha donde donde sea
lo mismo que hizo la persona a la que yo
le regalé
el perfume tomo todo eso pica lo tiró
una cantidad así de grande de material
total mente de gusto
vamos a ver
si ponemos nos podemos analizar este
tipo de cosas nos damos cuenta
tenemos situaciones realmente insólitas
a diario que hacemos con los plásticos
como encaramos el hacernos cargo de esos
plásticos
en mis más de 30 años de trabajo he
escuchado de su this y más discusiones
sobre si una bolsa entra en el mar
la tortuga cree que es una medusa
entonces tanto pasa esto es lo otro dice
sí claro porque si se mete adentro de el
esqueleto de plástico la tortuga le pasa
lo que la tortuga que les mostré pero
nadie absolutamente nadie dice nada
respecto de cómo hizo esa bolsa para
llegar ahí
porque no nos hacemos cargo nosotros de
lo que hacemos y generamos
y cómo podríamos hacernos cargo
qué podríamos hacer
y cuando me quedé reflexionando yo a
partir del precioso regalo que le llevé
a mi amiga
lo primero sería poder pensar un poquito
entre le llevó esa bellísima cosa o al
menos o me ahorro todo eso y le llevó
solamente la cajita porque esa no no la
puedo no por el momento en este momento
no puedo sacarme esa cajita lo que tenía
la cajita de encima pero ahorro un
montón en la medida que podamos en casa
no usar descartables por ejemplo esa es
otra de las maneras
porque no pesar las verduras de a uno y
ponerlas pedir en el supermercado aunque
a veces no nos dejen exigir insistir
poner todas las verduras en una
lo importante creo es no perder el eje
de las responsabilidades
el eje de láser nos cargo
el eje de que el material es un material
en sí mismo si nosotros hubiésemos
puesto las verduras en vez de una en
cada bolsita de plástico una en cada
bolsita de cartón hubiésemos tirado los
cartones como tiramos el plástico y
hubiese sido lo mismo se dan cuenta que
el material no es el problema sino la
persona que lo usa
así entonces si nosotros somos
coherentes y hacemos un uso racional
de los materiales que nos rodean primero
minimizando la cantidad ejemplo de la
compra con el packaging y segundo bueno
pero la basura que no nos queda otra y
generamos qué hacemos con esa allí
tenemos algunas posibilidades que si
hicimos coherentemente la primera parte
tenemos primero menos basura y segundo
la otra cosa que sí seguramente tenemos
es derecho a exigir a las instituciones
oa las empresas que las generan o las
ponen en el mercado que generen sistemas
de gestión integral de esos residuos
pero por lo pronto colaborar con los que
hay
esa es la idea
con la que quisiera que nos fuéramos
todos un poco hoy hacernos cargo porque
la pregunta es
vos estás dispuesto a hacerse cargo de
lo que generas de lo que usas los
plásticos que usas y tiras
estás dispuesto a generar un mundo mejor
qué vas a hacer para ese cambio muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]